Are opioids a human hormone, a prescription
medicine, or a deadly narcotic? Actually,
it can be all three. In fact, opioids are
not so foreign: they're found in our bodies.
Secreted by the pituitary and adrenal glands,
endogenous opioids are neurotransmitters that
our body synthesizes to regulate our response
to stimuli. Things like emotions, motivation,
and pain, are all regulated by endogenous
opioids. Exogenous opioids, as the prefix
"exo" suggests, are opioids not made or found
in our body. It can be natural, like morphine,
semi-synthetic, like heroine, or entirely
synthetic, like naloxone. Both types of opioids
bind to G protein coupled receptors, and the
activation of g proteins is what causes the
effect of opioids. Here is an example of a
mu-receptor with an agonist bound to the active
site. Broadly speaking, when opioids bind
and activate GPCRs, the activated GPCRs inhibit
the transmission of a neuronal signal from
one neuron to another. One way in which opioids
modulate neuronal signaling is through post-synaptic
inhibition. As opioids bind to GPCRs, colored
in red, potassium channels are opened, and
the positive potassium ions leave the neuron,
thus leaving no signal to be relayed to the
next neuron. Zoomed in, we see the activated
G protein release its G beta-gamma complex,
which activates the potassium channel and
causes hyperpolarization. Naloxone is a synthetic
derivative of oxymorphone intended to reverse
the antagonizing effects of opioids. In action,
while naloxone replaces the opioids bound
to GPCRs due to its higher affinity, it doesn't
activate the G proteins. Every day, a 130
plus people die from an opioid overdose. 10.3
million people misused prescriptions just
in 2018. If there's one thing you can do to
address the epidemic, avoid opioid derived
prescriptions prescriptions and recognize
that treatment, not punishment, is the answer.